hey Gary Evan Jacobs my question is you
talked about when you're setting up for
this book you you spend a lot of time
helping people helping people along the
way especially over the last year yes
this book was your right hook from a
different perspective you could see this
book as a jab to some a bigger right
hook so like say book book book New York
Jets right tonight you're 1000% correct
so no but you are because like even
within it right like I'm like it's me
those give me a my question is how how
how to make a right hook a jack a jab
for something bigger yes that's listen I
think the notion of writing books is
actually stupid I actually think it's
not a great business model I can make a
lot more I can do well I've been
thinking about like these retreat
consulting sessions not a masterclass
but some version of it a little bit
better than the bottom-feeding that I
think is going on in the mass market
where I can make more money in a
three-day trip to Turks and Caicos with
clients that I can through all this
process but I you know it's ironic I do
think of these as jabs it's actually the
answer to chases question earlier
there's a lot of people I can't consult
you know because I charged $80,000 a
month but this really is through and
through the truth and the secret and the
reason I really stood now and did in two
years ago is cuz I knew I had something
the reason I'm releasing it now is I've
trained enough people that it's gonna
get out there anyway so I might as well
put it out and own it I think this is
the best 30 dollar investment that
anybody can make I'm very proud of that
and you're absolutely right I do think
of this as a jab even though it is my
right hook and listen jabbing the right
hook is very complicated I think you try
to sell anything for 19 months of social
networks my first post in August hey my
new books coming can you buy five copies
if I brought you any value by the third
post in August right people like uh your
your [ __ ] selling too much Gary like
[ __ ] I haven't sold anything in
two years but so everybody has their you
know some people don't want to be sold
to ever and that's great and I respect
that so jabs and ROI hooks are there
isn't a perfect formula back to the
question earlier but I think you've got
me pegged I will throw right hooks that
feel as Jabby as possible because I have
this obnoxious North Star goal
professionally
I think you throw your ultimate all in
pure right hook when you're finished if
I decide at 62 that I don't want to
fight for it anymore that that I don't
want to miss more time with my family or
whatever my psyche is at that moment you
will see my final right hook and it will
be cashing in a shitload of chips and
it's gonna be very profitable you know
but for now I'm not in that place yes
it's a very very very good observation
Fanta